l'égérie du salon cette année c'était
tel cerise lavage bazadaise de 750 kg
une star quelque peu éclipsé par une
crise agricole venu perturber le salon
des stands détruit des politiques
hué et insulté cette année c'est
l'actualité qui prenait le pas sur la
découverte des produits locaux c'est
quand même une année
avec un grand changement dans la
politique puisqu'il ya une liberté
maintenant de produire
on arrive à une situation où il ya une
surproduction
où les prix sont en train de s'effondrer
il faut aussi que certains agriculteurs
trouvent des solutions en se regroupant
je suis agriculteur je meurs personne ne
pouvait passer à côté de ce message
affiché sur la plupart des stands ici
même si on participe au salon on
soutient quand même la cause c'est de
mettre en avant les produits ligne de
france lesquels on travaille au
quotidien en restaurant et puis
kim en fait un peu de 2
présence pour notre restaurant sur un
salon international d'agriculture qui
pour encourager donc on est présent pour
amber de la france on est apolitique et
mais on soutient les agriculteurs
évidemment un soutien qui passe par le
circuit court la vente directe du
producteur au consommateur les visiteurs
sont ils adeptes de cette pratique nous
leur avons posé la question aux jeux
bonnet oui parce que jamais de l'ariège
alors cinq véhicules à la base ça se
fait beaucoup et ça se pratique
énormément dans les produits de qualité
puis les produits qu'ils ont à me dire
que l'on trouve à côté la maison puis
c'est tout moi j'évite la compagnie je
vais dans les faire directement
j'ai acheté la viande la wii louise
élèves les ports les
la viande de boeuf là où ils élèvent les
boeufs et voilà le salon de
l'agriculture est aussi un moyen de
découvrir des producteurs proches de
chez vous depuis une semaine ce sont
déjà sept cent mille visiteurs qui se
sont rendus dans la plus grande ferme de
france